j'avais des grands projets
pour un grand animateur merde
ça comme français en effet je ne peux
plus attendre
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous faire une énorme révélation qui va
secouer le paf et qu'il ya eu ce même
secoué tôt pistes
pour vous dire
j'étais tranquillement en train de créer
jeudi soir
et j'ai eu trois magnifiques gillett
prime time fulgurances je vous hais ah
oui signalé la première s'était plaint
des petits yeux avec benjamin castaldi
la deuxième c'était vidéo gages avec feu
bernard montiel
2022 et la troisième ouais ouais c'était
wafou
une émission animalière où on rigole
avec mathieu de l'homme
j'appelle la chaîne
je propose à la chaîne ses trois prime
time
la chaîne emballé me dit c'est fait
c'est signé c'est fait c'est signer donc
on fera ses trois prime time ils étaient
emballés en battant bâle est emballé oui
c'est vrai il était vendu terminé
awards bien entendu je me dis bon
je vais appeler les animateurs sus nous
les intéressait j'appelle bernard
montiel
ça sonne ça ne répond pas
apparemment son téléphone a cramé dans
un point soleil
et puis je me dis toutes les façons est
ce que vous voyez bernard montiel nous
refuse un prime time non non non non on
est d'accord
j'appelle mariama castaldi jeudi
benjamin comment ça va qui ça va ça se
passe bien tu es contente un jour
accroche
je n'aime pas propos du jeu c'est très
bien qu'il refusera jamais
et là
je demande
à mon bras droit lionel stan
directeur général d'aj de zola boîte de
production
créée il ya maintenant plus d'une
dizaine d'années une boîte de production
sérieuse
numéro un en europe ait eu dans mon
numéro un en europe oui oui oui c'est
vrai
vous aviez donc au téléphone le
directeur général de la boîte de
production numéro un en europe et numéro
1 presque mondiale giuly non mais c'est
vrai pour le groupe numéro un mondial et
de groupe numéro un mondial
et lionel stade lui dit mathieu
bien entendu pour moi foufs
on a pensé à toi pour l'animation des
gens tueraient pour ça moi oui je n'ai
j'ai quitté le bureau à ce moment là je
ne voulais pas voir sa réponse est
d'ailleurs j'aurais trop mal
là lionel stan ne m'appelle pas
j'ai juste un sms
catastrophe 2.9
matthieu delormeau au fuse l'animation
quand même
[Musique]
un grand piano quand même
très très grand piano quand même
[Musique]
comment est ce possible
comment est ce possible avec la motion
n'avait pas alors c'est je me suis dit
c'est une stratégie trois solutions a
obligé tous matthieu delormeau refuse
pour avoir encore plus trop et
pare-brise miens deuxième possibilité il
a été tellement traumatisée par mouffe
qu'il a peur du waf waf au foot c'est
tout à fait compréhensible et crédible
ça ou
matthieu delormeau
en vue d'abréger sa carrière peut-être
de repartir vers ses premières amours la
police et le cinéma
les épaules mathieu et jean niel est ce
que vous avez peut-être une hypothèse
peut-être qu'ils sont pas capables après
tout peut-être qu'il a peur penser qu'il
n'est pas capable d'animer ouaf ouaf ouf
l'obstacle et j'ai zappé le waf bouffe
ouaf ouaf ouf précisons qu'il s'agit
d'un bêtisier animalier alors ne s'agit
pas du tout d'un bêtisier animalier est
alors compter sur teddy votre pas du
tout je vais vous raconter c'est toute
la bande de tpm paix qui vous reçoit en
direct sur le plateau avec des
happenings animalier et les images
animalière voilà on rigole on voit des
images comme ann mathieu delormeau et
ici à ma place
alexis
s'est pas il est sur un fond vert il
fait aller tout de suite on va retrouver
allez on va retrouver le fugitif il est
un jeune berger allemand de trois ans et
vous allez voir que quand fugitif a mal
à la pâte faut pas se trouve à côté
donc par matthieu lambeaux truc quand
même ah oui parce que je ne sais pas
peut-être ça faisait ça vous a été mal
vendu aujourd'hui c'était qu'il en veut
plus aujourd'hui
est ce que vous pouvez me regarder droit
dans les yeux et je comprendrais votre
décision il n'y aura aucune sanction à
celle à aucune bien au contraire à
centre a dû tout à vous en retirez que
ce sont toutes les façons de sortir
grandie c'est gentil pas de partout vous
aurez arrivées
mathieu réfléchi et matic maintenant que
vous avez eu le pitch de l'émission
ouais moi je m'imagine vous voyez comme
ça bonsoir à tous et même de la faf
après c'est là c'est l'explosion qui n'a
envie de voir cette émission moi
c'est un plébiscite match il y aura eu
envie de l'animé
bras moi j'écoute et je vous dirais même
pas déconner si vous ne le faites pas vu
c'est vous qui le ferait donc tu veux le
faire moi-même
compression un deuxième samia ou mia où
je vais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mathieu oui je me tourne vers vous savez
que tous les deux c'est toujours tout
dit avant d'être toujours été comme une
paire de boutargue ceux de
l'italien tunisien a repeint t'emmerder
pas exact de dire qu'on était très
pratique d'accord mathieu 1
je vais te demander ce soir à 18h48
après avoir eu le vrai pitch de
l'émission publique
de 100 personnes sont là que pour rire
le public tous les chroniqueurs
historique de tpb et les titulaires
n'ont service
civil an-nahar ton année on n'est pas
loin en régie
les images il
croit que cette magouille et des chiens
en veux tu en voilà ouaf ouaf ouf ça
sera sur ses huit un triomphe incroyable
porté par la famille pour l'instant
c'est la folie ça aujourd'hui c'est fou
ça
si je dois annoncer l'émission comment
passer à côté de celle et dans la foi je
mettrai ma foi souffrent ou sont souvent
animés pas parce que vous allez y un
chiffre également
[Rires]
cette info non pas d'être
animée avec jamel l'epagnol
un jeune épagneul breton de trois ans
magnifique la vie devant lui
à la levée par des éleveurs de champion
c'est sûr que le public a très envie
matthieu delormeau ma question est
simple elle est claire
est ce que
oui ou non est ce que vous voulez animée
si c'est oui c'est oui si c'est non
c'est non mais ça ne sera pas peut-être
ça ne sera pas je dois réfléchir je
respecterai toutes vos décisions et si
vous me dites non je vous aimerai autant
que si vous dites oui c'est à dire
quelles sont donc les 24 heures de
réflexion soit pas autorisée non avec
vous c'est comme ça vous avez déjà
depuis jeudi déjà les 72 heures on a
donc fait surtout sanaa s'en était vendu
comme ça du tout mal vivre en direct les
vues dire un mot elles soient pas
égoïste chez vous plaît à mouy français
planning déjà cyrille rogeau penser aux
animaux que devance ya tous les autres
j'avais déjà vous traînez c'est notre
amitié oui c'est vrai et je ne veux pas
d'oreiller pas des gros même vous avez
effectivement ap bernard montiel pour
lui demander
vous avez appelé benjamin castaldi pour
lui demander g vous avez laissé votre
directeur général m'a appelé pour me
demander ça m'a beaucoup vexé
francs capitaux qui m'appelle
président
rien n'a été booké avant oui
extraordinaire oui président mais mon
fils tu sais que suis à l'antenne et à
huy
et mathieu même la direction
mathieu tu sais la tan tout le groupe
canal qui est comme ça qu elle
non toi francs capitaux le grand
président si on n'a pas dormi pendant
deux jours
exactement
il au fond de son lit le thermomètre
affiche 38 3
et franck a plutôt peut perdre 2 degrés
de température sa puce parce qu'après ça
voudra dire qu'il sera là ma gauche
le degré de température en une décision
que tu ne seras pas vraiment le le butin
de cons en vrai deux mètres et que voilà
mardi la presse ne peut pas attendre bah
oui je vais te dire aujourd'hui ya et je
dis et je les ai sentis encore tout à
l'heure dans les transports en commun
les prix pour venir
[Rires]
jeudi je vis non mais je me dis je vais
encore sorti dans les transports en
commun encore tout à l'heure il ya une
énorme attente autour de ouf ouais les
gens à la station
dans mon élément de soutien aux canards
s'assurera de saint cloud sur la ligne
noms mais voilà les gens disaient on
attend avec impatience la décision de
matthieu delormeau je vous dire à ce
moment il ya deux décisions
qu'attendent les français est ce que
zemmour va se présenter et à ce que
matthieu delormeau va présenter bouffe
avec quand même une petite préférence
pour matthieu delormeau qui va
représenter vous est pas le coup mathieu
mathieu le président d'être appelé ouais
il décroche son téléphone que très
rarement way est un enjeu de kelowna
franck tu vas voir la décision chez toi
franck je peux donner juste un truc
[Musique]
président quelle que soit la décision
s'il te plaît franck ne commet pas
l'irréparable
sois fort
stock demande thomas service tu sais
comme ce thème c'est pas envie de te
perdre pour une conne mais bordel
mais j'espère qu'il prendra la bonne
décision merci franck je t'embrasse un
shérif du comté on t'aime
c'est fou c'est
vraiment
c'est un truc de fou des grands espaces
ouais
oui j'aurais dit mathieu que disent les
de leurs moeurs
et oui c'est vrai moi je pense que les
douleurs mres envie de voir mathieu bien
sûr les chéris moi je vais vous dire moi
je ne forcerai jamais personne à gagner
de l'argent
[Rires]
ça n'est pas mon genre vous le savez ça
n'est pas mon genre mais ce que je sais
c'est que mathieu moi je serais heureux
pour toi ouais je te défendrait bec et
ongles contre toute la presse animalière
qui va tout
j'imagine tout de suite le colibri
magazine holà on l'a vu il parle pas de
poids ut papa une fois de nous dans
l'émission pas une fois de colibri non
mais mathieu écoutons à vos chéris
maintenant ta décision je te proposes
tu as écrit combien voulez combien la
somme
les gens doivent tous avoir un au cas où
que tu as tu aurais pensé à quoi
on parle a annoncé vulgaire on parle par
jean paul écrit on parle longtemps on
parle juste séparés
alors j'espère si si si bien sûr très
bien comme un associé de la société en
matière lequel le préfère au verset
lamarre maire où vas tu la voulais
vraiment qui disent non à faire sur la
production version à quelque chose à
l'expiration talent à la production est
bon bien sûr matthieu delormeau prix des
animateurs a laissé vous plaît merci non
ne rajoutez pas alors c'est déjà
compliqué
mais voulez je vous dit quelque chose
c'est pas son argent je vous promets non
mais je vais vous dire quelque chose si
vous ne le faites pas ouais je le ferais
moment oui et je vais vous dire quelque
chose ouais bon jeu sérieux ou le ferait
tellement mieux non non macaire
d'animateur
j'annonce pas aujourd'hui mais dense et
strauss kahn
journal on a sous la halle berry
toujours nation alors attention oui
la donne une motivation pour motiver un
plébiscite alors ya déjà des chiens
devant la
table vous avez la france
[Rires]
derrière des liens twitter un twittos
mabrouk et juniors être ce 30 millions
d'amis qui jouent
alors
je suis à ce que voulait lui donner
votre avis avant qu'il prenne sa
disciple pas des ribéry moi je pense que
c'est toujours très bien d'exercer son
métier alors va te la mets à comme était
écrit oui son métier d'animateur bah oui
alors banon parce que parce qu'il est à
d'accord glaciers deviennent
d'artillerie qui a réclamé à corps et un
prime non mais toi tu rendras compte pas
sur une thématique que tu connais bien
oui pour les animaux mais voilà puisque
tu as surfer sur cette vague animalière
avec succès à mes larmes et c'est vrai
franchement il à sa future carrière à
vrai dire aujourd'hui enfin micro
trottoir entre de matthieu delormeau ont
du chien
donc moi je pense pas que j'aurai tort
heureux après vous pouvez peut-être fait
relâche academy plus d'être la star
c'est les chats qui chante
[Rires]
un succès pour de vrai mais je porte ce
prix on s'amuse bref que ce sera un
succès et ça sera très très attendu mais
oui je m'occuperai moi même la coop
rémoise de la com ah oui bien sûr
benjamin castaldi honnêtement on a
relâché très sérieux cette case pour toi
il ya zéro risque mais dans l'attende tu
dois real et réhabiliter ce format que
tu as déjà massacré première dame et
c'est l'occasion de prouver que tu peux
en faire un rien samedi voilà c'est tu
peux en faire un art it et en plus
honnêtement ce plateau avec de tous avec
toi on va t'accompagner de porter temps
mené vers le triomphe
ouaf ouaf ouaf ou non tu sortiras dans
la rue un bon choix février ouaf ouaf
ouf ouf mais ans
on s'est régalé j'étais avec mon poisson
rouge m'a tordu et on n'est pas niable
en plus on va faire 45% sur les animaux
c'est vrai ou sinon on m'appellera ouaf
ouaf hofouf dans le mais c'est vrai oui
ni non mais c'est vrai visionnaire dont
je vais parler avec mon coeur de marie
la carrière est en perdition
[Rires]
et cyril mais cyril qui est la bonté
incarnée qui doit alors on propose une
dernière chance dans l'abonnement l'on
sait non car elle dit aux dirigeants
d'aig a failli s'appeler litigieux
hérésie à la fois personnelle et
professionnelle que moi je vous en
supplie pour tous les techniciens qui
vont travailler pour nous pour le monde
animalier pour tout le monde dit tout
il a une impression là
je peux pas d atouts
isabelle moign son avis elle
le philosophe florent pagny visé samedi
soir il faut toujours finir ce qu'on a
commencé eh ben tu as commencé à entamer
une émission est franchement mal entamé
maintenant il faut l'achever et là on
est là pour détruire leurs arguments à
taux zéro nous achever d'accord très
bien donc pour vous il faut qu'il y ait
évidemment
merci c'est génial
raismes séquence où tu sais que la tdc
que de la télé moi j'aime pas qu'on
force les gens si tu veux pas le faire
marcher ou pas mais c'est un truc
totalement différent qu'on propose on
propose une bande totalement à ton
service on me propose d'être là bas à la
place de celle ci 200 personnes qu'est
ce que c'est que
le carré or c'est le carré vip caribbean
on arrête de dire mon poste dont on paye
a pas de poste ici on est une équipe
c'est le poste de tout le monde en fait
un entraîneur quand même
vu jouer
vous voyez le poste ne croyait pas si
bien orientées à l abri dont trois
va vous sinon
pourquoi vous êtes ruiner
[Applaudissements]
on vient de boire rien c'est que
rencontrent les quartiers pas
grand-chose abordait le voir voilà en
plus mathieu il faut que tu veux que je
te connaissent un peu plus ouais enfin
il faut que les gens te connaissent un
peu plus sa messagère est pas commun non
mais qu'est ce que tu veux que je te
remets ce qui s'est passé samedi soir a
alors dit au qatar mais parce que ça
nous venons
juste un conte samedi soir qu'est ce que
c'est ça c'est dit moi nous sommes allés
dîner ensemble à deauville oui et je
vais présenter le patron de l'hôtel
normandy laconi réfère n'était pas
décisif vient lui dire de normandie
merci cyril mais dans tulasne par
odyssée 2010 et enfin le patron c'est
dominique desseigne patron du groupe à
celui qu'ils avaient vu domine à non il
est pas là jean-marc de l'hôtel normandy
pas d'accord aquino gérance de gérant de
l'auberge
de
sanguinet s'il vous plaît
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il était dans cet hôtel normandy très
cher j'étais enceinte
propos il me dit dis non c'est chaque l
hôtel vous le royal n'ont pas du tout le
le polonais pzu franchement j'ai dû
payer 110 euros la nuit et y cohabiter
osseux centrale de 100 acres à la wii
mais cet homme dont
le centre est ce un restaurant ça va
[Applaudissements]
il est 3 heures du matin la delhi au
milieu du rhin ce temps là une
très bonne mais monsieur
centrale c'est la guerre jusqu'à 4
heures du matin y'a des mecs qui servent
c'est là où tu m'as manger quand t'as
plus rien c'est très bon et donc elle
réclamait donc oui il a dormi toute la
ville 4ème tome est un [ __ ] tu peux la
mouche au commerce par
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci
j'imagine aux orane aucun dégât colonies
au milieu par l'assiette de la mer là
c'était attention monsieur fait gaffe à
la moule non joueurs soit pas là merci
et vue l'idée ou nishio normandie du
pays ça il ne t'inquiètes pas j'ai un
plan et ce soir on dîne ensemble et
j'appelle le directeur général normand
dit je te fais une passe décisive alors
à l'hôtel à l'oeil la suite le volant
voilà leur ai dit que donc les acteurs
arrivent je présenterai taroudant pas te
faisais bd videmment d'unités du
delormeau et au bout d'un moment les
dacquois mes limites mais vous
[Applaudissements]
on parlait de normandie deauville de la
plus jeune avait rien à [ __ ] et je
voulais qu'il parlait jamais de moi donc
aborder julie sinon vous aimez un peu ce
que je fais vous faites
allez vous travailler au centre
je suis comme un geste
[Applaudissements]
salies ont valu de la cen-sad a pu
l'empêcher là
on vous envoie pas fou peut-être que
cela pourra découvrir à une image alors
je me demande si la chaîne va pas durer
si vous êtes là
peut-être parce que vous êtes assez
populaire pour animaux
je me posais complète
je crois qu'il m'a pris en grippe mais
peut-être mais je crois qu'il est très
peu connu sur la normandie parce que je
me suis dit sur cette région là c'est
quand même un central où elle trois
chambres les basques chaudière en
normandie les gardes en normandie
d'ailleurs je les embrasse les gens
normandie et on a demandé à un truc qui
ferait pas ce que les normes au bout des
tests en fait sur un carré noir
se dévouent regardant le redis n'est pas
là dans cette région et d'ailleurs est
nominé au splendid voilà merci
j'adorerais jolie géo elle est
magnifique aussi beaucoup manifestent un
joli alors
houphouët est un naufrage on peut le
dire on va vous va être un triomphe ravi
ouaf ouaf ou être un triomphe et je
pense que tu as besoin de ça laisse que
je pense que ça a été pour toi un
traumatisme vraiment celle des personnes
un échec personnel absolument comme dit
valérie un homme blessé et je pense que
justement il va falloir que tu fasse
preuve dans sa deuxième partie de
carrière puisque t'es pas loin de 50 ans
[Rires]
s'il vous plaît justin je vous adore
machina j'aimerais alors est pas con un
dépressif la
normandise adore les animaux donc voilà
c'est vrai je fais chier mais chabal
et j'entends
les amas je suis prêt mais de genthod
qui revient à envoyer qui est avec
thomas pesquet des regards
ah mais l'envié d'être avec lui encore
regarde je suis prêt à mettre à
disposition les trois chiens pour
l'émission beaucoup de
monde qu'on ait des accidents énorme
aide à la fois kaka qui a calé chez lui
ça a été compliqué et ensuite je veux
une info médias j'ai été contacté pour
faire les magnétos de cette émission non
menara de nombreux chiens qui pète et
autres
[Rires]
juste là je viens de vous retirer là
je viendrai joue bien nous la regardons
de près la veille je viens vous la
retirer on va de fait le fada je rigole
moshiri accord faut que je prenne un peu
d'oseille dit oui s'il te plaît mais
cela se fera même sans moi mathieu oui
et pour toi match il est 19 heures 6 et
aujourd'hui
l'heure est à la décision
matthieu delormeau
va-t-il
animer ce
que tous les animateurs de france
de navarre et normandie nous envie
ouaf ouaf
ouf
s'est arrêté sur le titre le titre a
fait grand bruit il ya la direction de
canal+ les vendeurs c'est un mandat fort
tous les chroniqueurs seront là je serai
dans les locaux bien entendu accompagné
de deux ou trois chiens et chats est ce
que je ne sais pas si dans ouaf ouaf ou
phonique des chiens ou des geisha je
pense qu'il ya tout type animaux je
serai également avec une bonne est
original avec des chiens mais la parité
aussi dans la vo tu voulais avec des
chiens alors ça n'est pas du tout un
dérivé de bouffe c'est une autre
émission et à une autre émission tournée
vers l'avenir
tournée
vers les gens qui aiment les animaux qui
aime la vie et sachez que netflix m'a
contacté pour
huawei impressionnant matthieu delormeau
et ma question est simple elle est
claire
voulez vous
animez
dabo lieu de beaulieu de beaulieu de blé
ouaf ouaf ouaf hossein moussavi
magazines dits oui dit oui
alors que ça n'est pas le juste prix
[Musique]
mais j'ai peur mais moi j'ai peur alors
cyril oui
ouf ne fut pas un très bon souvenir
malgré un score très correct je crois
qu'on en parle à la même chaîne six cent
cinquante mille téléspectateurs le
samedi c'est tombé lozère
on a eu des chiffres au bordel arrêter
comme ça vous mettions donc j'ai fait me
lèverai ci alors
et
je suis très bien à cette place en ce
moment à vos côtés je sais ce serait
bien aussi
et malgré
le fait que je sois très touché par
cette offre voilà je préfère quoi elle a
vécu ni non
c'est un coup de tonnerre
c'est un coup de tonnerre en place au
caire matthieu delormeau au caire
matthieu delormeau refuse ouaf ouaf
hofouf gérer les séries d'echery je vais
faire ce que je ne fais jamais je
m'élance un chrono de deux minutes
différents chroniqueurs va avoir deux
minutes pour le faire changer d'avis
c'est à l'issue de ces deux minutes il
n'a pas changé d'avis c'est terminé je
désignerai une autre personne rené pour
animaux ouaf ouaf hofouf et ça peut être
n'importe qui même isabelle aaa mais
vous êtes en bonne et moi autant vous
dire qu'on va au devant de gros gros
coup la
jeune soprano oui oui je vais lancer un
chrono de 3 minutes pour le faire
changer d'avis chaque chroniqueur aura
un truc à lui dire mathieu je ne parlais
pas ils vous nous donnerez votre vraie
décision
réfléchie
c'est parti chrono nourdine volé car j'y
ai eu
mathieu est ce que tu penses vraiment
que tu as une fierté à avoir parce que
j'ai peur que tu crois que tu as une
fierté accepte parce que là c'est un peu
le on veut ramener nos chiens on veut
qui fait avec toi on veut qu'ils veulent
amener avec nos animaux t'as pas de
fierté alors dit oui
écoutez ne parlait plus je vous le
demande sur nos services
les cherry et arrêtez moi ce chrono
parce qu'on va au devant de gros preuve
ne parle que ceux qui ont de bons
là on est en train de [ __ ] en l'air
cette [ __ ] démisssion ghana ghs liste
c'est une zone airbus a raison il faut
que je bouge non je n'ai pas pu faire
confirmer
[Rires]
merci chers a dit monsieur on a des ouf
comment on a deux vies la deuxième
commence quand on s'aperçoit qu'on en a
qu'une auberge prend un risque sur
prends toi et moi ne reste pas dans ta
zone de confort tu excellent chroniqueur
mais tu peut exceller dans war of proof
et si ça se trouve il y aura parlé en
ces votations éviter de dire le titre
devant commencer comme assez
évident venus des banlieues d'un bolide
mais c'est pourtant c'est mieux forts
devenus et sur l'apple store de benoît
mais ça va mieux on peut l'appeler de
bodio fort n'ont voulu c'est bien tard
devenu aux attentes mais qui a des
arguments je pars et je suis pas sûr
valérie bénaïm s'il vous plaît mathieu
fordo boyoud c'est fait pour toi le
hashtag est déjà là fort de beaulieu toi
qui est bilingue que le keyword wild qui
internationale c'est fait pour toi par
ailleurs tu ne vit que pour et par ton
public et ton public a plébiscité faute
de bots you ton public tu veux à plus de
60 % oui moi tu ne peux pas refuser
pendant soixante dix pour
dire non
imparable implacable écoute moi ça ne
change pas un homme un homme ça vieillit
dans la vie on a mûri
j'ai deux filles
on aimerait pouvoir rejouer des matches
on n'a jamais l'occasion de rejouer ce
match comme ça là tu as l'occasion de
rejoindre je vais demander à la régie de
montrer la photo où tu es avec
l'animatrice est ce que tu pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le même mec qui
mettrait la main dans la poche comme ça
est très chiant la vie est comme jamais
de la vie pour effacer sa réponse anna
grodzka
reste encore 52 secondes
maintenant reste évidemment mathieu il
faut que tu améliores cette notoriété
dont on a besoin
mais cette normandie
yoplait gilles verdez que les un génie
mais à mon post yoplait
ne vous foutez pas
vraiment je reviens tout entendre mais
je ne veux pas non plus qu'on d'un ami
robert matu on en a besoin cyril le
producteur te parle si tu le fais pas
pour nous pas pour toi saint lô pour lui
et c'est naturellement
sur il terminerait dans le mur est ce
que c'est ce que cet homme-là serait
capable oui
on va la télé est ce que cet homme mais
c'est le producteur aussi bien je
demande deux choses
attentatoire à sa décision ouais je
recommande les deux choses pour
l'instant tu fermes ta gueule
je serai très sympa ce prime cheikh
grattant battu pour l'instant ne donne
pas la décision est-ce que canivet de
béni oui oui mathieu c'est pour toi que
je me dois de le dire tu sais que je
connais la vie tout le monde ici et je
sais que tu passes tes nuits tout seul
un
événement accompagné d'un chien dans son
lit tu me la dina la 1re fois
les saints est vraiment
parce qu'il est personne qui remue la
queue dans
un truc qui remue la queue et pieds
poilus c'est pas forcément chiant à
niteroi zoonit donc voilà non mais car
s'il vous plaît je lui ai demandé une
minute de plus qu'un mois
plus d'avoir quand même plus jabbar
l'argument de l'ami vous voulez
l'argument de mamie est alors trop chaud
j'emmène ralentir un peu le rythme
permettait et ben si tu présente
émission que tu promets qu'ils ne
seraient pas ça c'est un bon argument ça
vous avez raison
vous écoutez en fait je suis le meilleur
je vous dis quand je vous dis mathieu
musique
débrouillez vous mettez moi une musique
ne
cherche jamais témoin une musique de
piano bar
d'après en surprises à céret tapez sur
google
alors il ya nourdine qui me dit la
tempête a planté je la rolande laon
nordine tu me diras compte maintenant
temps d
arrêter surtout arrêter ce temps je vais
lui parler
matthieu delormeau chers téléspectateurs
il 19h25 nous sommes en direct ses
débuts les vacances de la toussaint
c'est le producteur qui parle ou l'ami
ou les deux vous saurez bien assis tout
n'a
aujourd'hui
mathieu dans la merde voilà tu es
revenue dans touche pas à mon poste ça
après moult et moult aux conversations
qu'on a eu tous les deux
mathieu on s'est dit énormément de
choses
et je t'ai dit
dans cet hôtel un sur cette terrasse oui
c'est vrai c'est un hôtel ah oui c'est
vrai oui c'est un dos tres moi c'est pas
parce qu'on ne comprend pas de chambre
que c'est pas un hôtel
[Rires]
on était dit mathieu tu est pour moi
un des cinq meilleurs animateurs que je
n'ai jamais vu ces trois noms
maintenance et 5
6 3 bah oui
bah oui tout évolue mathieu aujourd'hui
tu sais j'ai l'impression que tu comme
un oiseau corps échoués sur mon balcon
c'est un oiseau blessé à qui on aurait
cassé une patte
et cet oiseau pp jeudi
cui cui d'oise où
les moignons je vais te soigner et là
j'ai mis un sparadrap sur sa patte et
l'oiseau
est reparti et toi j'en vis ce que tu
sois cet oiseau que je te lance comme ça
et que tu t'envoles dans la vie des
gens c'est une image coude à
mathieu aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il est temps que tu sois non
seulement chroniqueur mais également
animateur
tu en as le physique tu en a les
capacités
tu en as et le teint
et tu en as j'espère
échos renaître
après quinze ans que j'ai des matières d
un pour moi tu n'es plus un animateur
depuis longtemps
c'est vrai c'est peut être cruelle des
normands
mathieu aujourd'hui tu as l'occasion de
rebondir
à toi de me dire où je rebondis avec
ouaf ouaf ouf
fort d'un but you où je m'éteins à
jamais comme un briquet un concert de
patrick bruel après qui a le droit
avec celle qui va sauter par la fenêtre
c'est plus loin d'eau non l'oiseau on
laisse tomber
ce prime va marcher ouais sur ce prime
n'aura certainement d'autres elle a un
jour tu diras gens reprennent une
interview dans le monde télérama
libération encore télé loisirs et
détente à meymac où les inrocks que tu
liras ya eu un avant et un après ouaf
ouaf ouf ouf pour moi d'être culte
mathieu
cette émission a détaillé pour toi il ya
des animaux tu les aimes il ya des
hommes tu les aimes ou tu mens il ya de
l'eau deux ans tu m il ya du direct
manque un truc alors qu'ils n'y soient
causés
avocat et sa plus que les animaux
d'ailleurs alors quoi à mathieu ouais
bah c'est reparti tu veux plus jamais
remettre au piano elle est bien cette
musique
martin c'est sa passion
faire ça
[Musique]
réfléchir tu me regardes oui
mais si on regarde au niveau tu
animée
ouaf ouaf
bof
ce sera ton ultime décision tu as dit
non une première fois as-tu dire non une
deuxième fois
[Musique]
et pourquoi
lui et pas là pour rien mathieu oui
ici j'ai un petit bouton
team hategeka puis ici des dizaines de
berger allemand qui veut
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
non
l'entrée stèle de l'équipe on dort dîne
l'aude et franchement pas mal
je leur demande et de musique mais bon
j'aurais trouvé ça veut dire les boîtes
chaîne et sans toujours mais bruyant on
aborde la botola
non non tu fais ce que tu veux et je te
le jure ouais tu seras toujours dans mon
coeur toujours mon ami toujours je te
proposerais bien sûr d'autres choses tu
dis non à ça je pourrai proposer un
autre truc plus tard à l'eonia ou pas
tout de suite dans cinq six ans mais non
là vraiment non s'il vous plaît là on
est sérieux et mathieu
c'est le paf qui t'attend là toutes les
autres chaînes se dit at-il dit oui
va-t-il dire non latines nous faire mal
vacquières ferme à la concurrence
n'oublions pas que nagui n'oubliez pas
les paroles c'était pour remplacer
n'oublions pas les paroles de nagui
regarde n'oublions pas les paroles
qu'est ce que c'est bon ça c'est dans
les livres
tu peux amener des canettes au
café des sports et
mat
aujourd'hui c'est un tournant dans votre
carrière mathieu est ce que oui ou non
vous voulez animée oui ouaf ouaf
hofouf qui pense qu'il va dire oui
beinheim je le souhaite en tout cas oui
il va dire oui kelly chase fret vous
l'avez retourner va dire oui alors
ça fait longtemps qu'il attend ça mais
c'était pas bon
mais oui si oui
ne me laisse pas m'asseoir à côté de
valérie dit oui sinon je vais venir
m'asseoir là bas tu va disparaître à
tout jamais
fait pas cette connerie maquis c'est
vrai en plus on va devoir peut-être
remettre
bernard montiel
des amis qui m'ont venir
et je le redis ouais bien entendu
mathieu si vous dites non nous
proposerait d'autres prime plus tard
vous serez toujours là et vous serez
toujours la pierre angulaire de touche
pas à mon poste a fait bien entendu donc
ça ne change rien si vous dites non au
contraire on en rigolera bah oui si vous
dites oui bien sûr on en rigolera on
fera un triomphe
juste j'ai besoin avant que vous disiez
oui
quand même qu'on parle un petit peu osé
vous d'abord l'accord facture bien
entendu on verra bien
non non non non non non cette facture
sur les géniales steuplaît passé c'est
génial ici vous connaissez ça alors ça
c'est incroyable assez forte vous plaît
si on peut vraiment écriture et
régionaux des niveaux
extraordinaires ep chez vous 9 ça c'est
une limitation de vitesse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment noir et de maintenance aux
séries le monde à l'eau
mais paris et londres il aimerait tous
les doutes et s'en va mais la patte
cassée
et la la la la non non on est chez nous
certains créneaux raisonnables s'ils
sont raisonnables dépêche toi parce que
tu as deux doigts de manière systémique
non mais c'est un tarif
avec un descendant mais un dessin
non non là là on n'y arrivera pas bien
oui dernier prix a pris option
parce que les oiseaux les mâles 5 et 10
6 1 sur la table tant beaucoup moins
aimables dépêchez vous l'anem darche et
soyez raisonnables qui résoudra pas la
tête ces pigeons c'est le jeu mais
jamais en dessous jamais déjà on veut
voir sinon moi j'ai plus ma des efforts
la rentrée nous
j'allais les chiens alors maintenant on
va pour des problèmes hanoune a montré
en train de priver 70% des français
moi je le voyais voler comme un oiseau
avec ma droite était comme ça répare et
tu meures casse la deuxième c'est ça je
retourne dans mon lit je retourne sur le
balcon battus à tomber en position ses
rythmes ok mais tellement les animaux et
qui dormait salle avec un chine la wii
pas mal non ban
attend donc allé voir dans quel sens
tu vas pas bien près de mettre
[Applaudissements]
une grosse claque énorme la tâche non
mais la voiture en train en facture mais
venez en voiture au monde démarre et on
parle en euros mais vous venez passer
pour devoir en fait sur ce territoire
ont fait mini minutes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
fin
quand on est plus qu on est animateur à
la merde m'a dit oui il arrive c'était
beaucoup plus prolixe après attention
des coûts de revient attention places la
non ne tenez pas peut-être ta ta ta fais
gaffe c'est énorme déjà eh oui si on est
quelque chose de toi c'est dingue et ce
en quoi ces énormes axa voilà c'est ça
qui me fait pas chier mais la somme
du début elle était elle était la
victime est champion du monde quand même
enfin j'ai encore 40 secondes pour
négocier au bout de fonctionnement des
rifains je me fais en existe mais plus
j'aime mais je descende sous pas prêt
obtenu à temps a passé mais il s'est
fait non baala fallait pas c'est terminé
c'est terminé dans ce cas là je sois tu
es pas du tout va bien faire vous savez
comme disait je vais faire une rigueur
doivent aussi
dire quelque chose vraie le prix qu'on
te donne ce n'est pas le prix que tu vas
toucher oui c'est le prix que l'autre
pense que tu
[Rires]
penses
que je veux pas tellement lionel messi
vous crois qu elle mais si les pays ont
besoin d'elle pepsi
il
on va faire une émission là en toute
amitié et que natal jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission par me donne et a décidé
alors moi je ne connais pas les mais je
devrais te dire moi ça c'est non c'est
sûr et certain non sérieux c'est certain
ce n'est pas sérieux qui ne la zéro
chance fera jamais un passé assez
déterminés bacon terminée mais les deux
cornes double du temps alors c'est ne
sait si sûr j'ai envie d'entendre on
fera on va se retrouver dans un instant
avec lequel est la question
puis tout matthieu delormeau
malheureusement on va leur vient de
passer à côté
alors c'est pas grave on mathieu je
t'aime et on fera d'autres choses
ensemble
je vais vous dire là en ce moment
j'aurais très peu de gens qui considère
à la baisse et je sais de qui je parle
selon bercy